Gaal:
Only we can shorten the
darkness.
♪♪
(Growling)
David Goyer:
People have been trying to make
Foundation for over fifty years.
Foundation was an enormous
influence for Star Wars.
David Goyer:
It was the greatest science
fiction work of all time.
David Goyer:
The story is sprawling, the
scope is sprawling.
David Goyer:
It unfolds over the course of a
thousand years.
♪♪
David Goyer:
If ever there were a company
that was hoping to sort of,
better people’s lives
David Goyer:
through technology, through
connectivity, it’s Apple.
David Goyer:
And that’s something very much
that Asimov was hoping to do.
♪♪
They're going to arrest me
tomorrow...and you.
♪♪
It's almost a certainty.
Hari:
You're familiar with my work,
psychohistory?
Yes... in theory, but I don't
know what it has to do with...
It's not a theory.
♪♪
Salvor:
They’re worried you can predict
the future.
♪♪
Hari:
They're worried people believe I
can.
♪♪
Hari:
And they don't like the future I
predict.
♪♪
Hari:
The empire will fall.
♪♪
Hari:
Order will vanish.
♪♪
Hari:
These massive events rushing to
meet us.
♪♪
(Growling)
Gaal:
Only we can shorten the
darkness.
♪♪